[Music]
hallelujah
what the hell are you doing i'm gonna
make this big for my great-grandson's
graduation barbecue i know you want
barbecue ribs but do you have any room
for roasted brown what
the hell you gonna buy me another damn
treat
my baby is graduating
i am so proud of you thank you for
letting me stay here come here anytime
you won't dare night as long as you
don't stay too long you're leaving right
after graduation right baby
wakanda forever
who is this is proud i'm a brown too no
you're more
you all hear about the break loot now
there's the legal way then there's the
medellin brawless and loads
[Music]
we sometimes just gotta do crazy stuff
get a fly
shoulda caught a video
it was december first 1955. when i was
young at six i'm 20 years old so if you
weren't 20 back then you'd be about 95
no no black don't crack
unless you're using it
jesus the lord god almighty mm-hmm he
can turn water into wine he did yeah i
got to go to the liquor store to get
mine want somebody praise him
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you